nous allons continuer nos auditions de
la matinée celle-ci fait aussi l'objet
d'une captation vidéo et nous
poursuivons nos travaux par l'audition
de madame Lise alter qui est la
directrice générale de l'agence de
l'innovation en santé il s'agit d'une
jeune agence qui a été lancée au mois de
novembre dernier dans le cadre du Plan
innovation santé 2030 et dont madame
alter est la première directrice
générale vous savez mes chers collègues
toute l'importance que notre commission
attache à ce sujet le Sénat va
d'ailleurs adopté en février dernier
enfin 2022 une proposition de loi
relative à l'innovation santé
canidémon et moi même avion cosigné nous
sommes donc particulièrement heureux de
vous recevoir aujourd'hui Madame la
Directrice je vous invite à vous
exprimer dans un propos liminaire et
notamment nous présenter les conditions
de la mise en place de votre agence
votre feuille de route les moyens de
vous disposer pour atteindre
actualité oblige vous pourriez peut-être
également commenter les annonces faites
hier par le Président de la République
en matière de lancement des nouveaux
instituts hospitaliers universitaires
les nouveaux CHU et les bio les bio
clusters il y a également même si c'est
un peu éloigné peut-être mais la mission
interministérielle qui a lancé la
première ministre pour faire des
propositions sur les mécanismes de
régulation et de financement des
produits de santé dans lequel beaucoup
de médicaments innovants sont inclus et
il y a beaucoup d'interrogations à ce
sujet dans les auditions les rencontres
que que moi enfin que je fais ou mes
collègues font également dans ces
domaines de l'innovation des thérapies
géniques et autres donc je vous laisse
la parole madame alter
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs je suis très heureuse d'avoir
l'opportunité effectivement
et c'est une première ici de vous
présenter l'émission les objectifs et le
contexte de la création de l'agence de
l'innovation en santé
je vais essayer effectivement de vous
dresser un petit peu le contexte de sa
création c'est ça de route et le contenu
de la mission et effectivement je
resituerai également le les travaux de
l'agence de l'innovation en santé dans
le cadre du Plan France 2030 et des
annonces majeures dans le domaine de la
recherche biomédicale
d'hier alors l'agence de l'innovation a
été envisagée dans le contexte du
lancement du Plan innovation santé
France 2030 en octobre 2021 l'agence
était d'ailleurs une des mesures de ce
plan
un plan qui concerne évidemment
tous les domaines
de de l'innovation bien au-delà de la
santé c'est un plan de 54 milliards
d'euros autour de 10 verticales dont
l'objectif est vraiment d'investir dans
l'ensemble des domaines relatifs à
l'innovation depuis la recherche
fondamentale en passant par le transfert
de technologie l'innovation et
l'industrialisation dans l'ensemble des
verticales avec un enjeu fort en matière
de décarbonation et de part de
financement au service des acteurs
émergents notamment startups et et
s'agissant de la santé 7 milliards 5
d'euros dédiés à la santé avec là encore
cette volonté vraiment très claire
d'investir à la fois le domaine de la
recherche fondamentale
de la recherche sensationnelle de la
recherche clinique de l'accès au marché
et de l'industrialisation et de la
production en assurant vraiment un
continuum pour faire en sorte que les
innovations puissent non seulement
émerger de la recherche française mais
ensuite réellement être développé sur le
territoire national pour pouvoir ensuite
bénéficier au patients je pense que
c'est vraiment ça le l'enjeu majeur de
ce plan innovation France 2030 sur ces
7,5 milliards de d'euros et donc je vais
faire tout de suite le lien avec les
annonces d'hier environ un milliard 5
sont dédiés à la recherche biomédicale
avec une politique de site extrêmement
ambitieuse
donc autour évidemment de d'annonces
faites autour de biocluster qui vont
être des des clusters de dimensions
mondiale avec un exemple prix notamment
sur le cluster de Boston donc en France
un premier lieu cluster avait été
annoncé à Paris Saclay autour du cancer
donc d'autres clusters ont été annoncés
hier notamment
autour d'enjeux
extrêmement important aussi et qui reste
bien les stratégies du plan France 2030
je pense notamment aux enjeux de la
bioproduction et des maladies
infectieuses émergentes et des vaccins
également des annonces faitières autour
de nouveau
institut hospitalo-universitaires donc
des centres d'excellence qui avait déjà
été lancés par le passé et donc on
continue sur cette lancée avec cette
conviction que finalement c'est aussi à
travers une politique de sites donc au
sein de ces de ces structures finalement
connectées les enjeux là encore des
équipes de recherche des entrepreneurs
des industriels également et des équipes
de soins pour faire en sorte que les
innovations puissent se développer et
qu'on puisse également
réussir à la phase de transfert de
technologie pour accélérer le passage de
la recherche au partenariat notamment
avec des entrepreneurs pour faire vivre
ensuite les innovations et les déployer
en France pour qu'elles arrivent ensuite
directement aux patients
au-delà de ces sites importants donc
biocluster et IHU des investissements
majeurs dans la recherche également
accordé au cohort structuration des
coortes anciennes et nouvelles au
biodank aux enjeux également
d'attractivité de la recherche clinique
avec une cinquantaine de chair en santé
pour attirer des talents sur le
territoire national et donner aussi
envie aux chercheurs français de rester
en conduisant des des projets de
recherche avec des équipements
extrêmement coûteux donc leur permet
vraiment de d'avoir les moyens de
conduire leurs recherches en France
donc voilà des investissements majeurs
sur la recherche et puis ensuite des
investissements conduits par stratégie
d'accélération donc 2 milliards d'euros
sont dédiés à ces grandes stratégies que
je vais vous rappeler donc en priorité
biomédicament et biomroduction puisqu'on
sait qu'aujourd'hui on est extrêmement
dépendant de nos importations en matière
de biomédicament
moins d'une dizaine de biomédicaments
sont produits en France sur le sur le
territoire national
il est il est clairement envisagé dans
dans produire au moins une vingtaine à
horizon 2030 pour prévenir justement
notre dépendance face à ces
biomédicaments qui vont qui représente
aujourd'hui la majorité des innovations
et on estime que à horizon 2025 parmi le
top 100 des médicaments prescrits au
moins la moitié représenteront des
biomédicaments et vous rappeliez aussi
les enjeux de la mission sur la
régulation et le financement des
produits de santé
on a bien en tête que
les enjeux relatifs aux médicaments de
thérapie innovantes sont extrêmement
importants et d'ailleurs j'ai à mes
côtés monsieur fontaine Vienne qui est
notre responsable prospective au sein de
l'agence et nous nous appelons et c'est
une des missions prioritaires de
l'agence à mettre en place un système
d'horizonique en tout cas de veille et
de prospectives en santé pour pouvoir
anticiper l'arrivée des innovations sur
le territoire et mieux préparer le
système de santé à les intégrer à la
fois sur le plan organisationnel et
financier ça c'est un enjeu majeur qu'on
a de connecté ces initiatives pour être
certain que notre système ne subissent
plus l'arrivée des innovations mais soit
vraiment dans une capacité à les
anticiper pour mieux préparer le
notamment le l'environnement hospitalier
en tirant le son un petit peu des des
expériences passées donc voilà
médicament thérapie innovante c'est
extrêmement important deuxième stratégie
d'accélération autour des maladies
infectieuses émergentes et des menaces
NRBC donc nucléaire radiologique
biologique et chimique là encore une
stratégie qui tire son origine
évidemment de la crise covid comme vous
le savez l'objectif est vraiment de
faire en sorte que notre notre système
de santé soit mieux préparé par rapport
à la survenue possible de crise qui sera
difficile évidemment d'anticiper
parfaitement mais en tout cas pouvoir
prioriser un certain nombre de
pathogènes prioritaires et de développer
des contreesures mais aussi faire en
sorte que notre système soit soit plus
résilient et adapté à la réaction
notamment face à des crises sur les
aspects plus organisations et
réglementaires et puis enfin une
stratégie d'accélération autour du
numérique en santé qui est piloté par un
coordinateur sur cette stratégie qui est
au sein de la DNS la délégation au
numérique en santé au ministère de la
Santé et vous connaissez
évidemment vous êtes extrêmement
sensibilisés à ces enjeux du numérique
qui aujourd'hui sont
un enjeu majeur de du système que ce
soit sur le volet data donnée de santé
mais aussi organisation des soins
télésurveillance telle expertise et les
consultations on voit bien aujourd'hui
que le numérique irradie l'ensemble de
notre système
contribue aux innovations
organisationnelles qui sont clés dans le
contexte de l'accès aux soins donc qui
rejoignent des enjeux beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus larges évidemment que
l'innovation mais c'est c'est
fondamental de les intégrer dans cette
dans ces enjeux en matière d'innovation
et puis enfin un plan sur le dispositif
médical innovant qui a été sur Ajouter
secondairement mais qui est majeur
également puisque on voit bien
aujourd'hui l'importance d'investir ce
domaine avec notamment tout ce qui va
être des innovations mixtes en matière
de dispositif qui est embarque de
l'intelligence artificielle évidemment
également qui vont concerner aussi le
bloc de demain avec tout ce qui concerne
la réalité virtuelle la robotique
les prothèses évidemment
en tout cas il est vraiment important
d'investir ce domaine où on voit bien
aujourd'hui qu'on est en difficulté en
France en Europe aussi mais
particulièrement en France sur notre
capacité
à avoir des évaluations par les
organismes notifiés rapides et efficace
qui permettent d'avoir des débouchés à
ces innovations qui naissent très
souvent la recherche française mais qui
ensuite sont lancés dans d'autres pays
en Europe et dans le monde aux
États-Unis évidemment de façon majeure
avec des agréments FG qui sont beaucoup
plus rapides que les agréments par les
organismes notifiés marquage CE donc ça
c'est un enjeu extrêmement important
auquel agence est sensibilisée mais à ce
stade quand même un petit un niveau
d'inquiétude mais je vous en parlerai un
peu plus précisément pour vous indiquer
ce qu'on a décidé d'entreprendre pour
essayer de
traiter ce sujet
donc évidemment la mission prioritaire
de l'agence et c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle a été créée entre autres
ça va être de suivre et de piloter les
mesures et les crédits de ce plan France
2030 sur la verticale santé mais bien
au-delà de ça et ça reflète bien la
spécificité du secteur de la santé qui
est extrêmement régulée et normé et
dans un objectif également
de conserver notre système de solidarité
nationale et de faire en sorte qu'il
puisse être soutenable
l'agence de l'innovation en santé donc a
pour mission d'investir le champ de la
prospective en santé encore une fois je
le répète c'est fondamental pour avoir
cette vision globale et se préparer sur
le plan financier organisationnel à
l'arrivée des innovations également sur
la base des besoins médicaux non
couverts d'aider les ministères à
définir les priorités en matière de
recherche puisque c'est aussi en
regardant ce qui arrive dans le pipeline
de développement et en matière
d'innovation de rupture qui se développe
quelles sont les cas d'usages qui
peuvent survenir dans le domaine de la
santé c'est aussi comme ça qu'on va
permettre là encore de prendre les
bonnes décisions notamment en matière de
d'investissement de la recherche en lien
avec un terminal ce qui n'est pas
contradictoire avec l'idée également de
soutenir des projets de recherche qui
viennent du terrain et qui sont pas
nécessairement drivés par le niveau
national mais je pense que les deux
approches doivent être complémentaires
les 2ème et troisième mission qui se
traduisent par des pôles à part entière
au niveau de l'agence de l'innovation en
santé
concerne l'accélération et la
transformation et l'accompagnement des
projets innovants avant de vous les
décrire je voudrais juste vous rappeler
que l'agence donc à une lettre de
mission de la première ministre elle est
rattachée au secrétaire général pour
l'investissement et là donc cette
vocation interministérielle qui est
importante d'avoir en tête puisque je
pense que c'est vraiment ce qu'il a
singularise et ce qui justifie même son
existence l'idée étant vraiment de
connecter les enjeux de la recherche du
soin de la santé et de l'industrie je
pense que c'est un ayant cette vision
holistique et globale qu'on réussira
vraiment à faire émerger les innovations
et à traiter ce sujet de façon complète
donc le deuxième pôle qui est le pôle
accompagnement a pour mission comme son
nom l'indique d'accompagner les les
projets innovants prioritaires lorsque
l'agence elle a été envisagée il était
souhaité qu'elle puisse faire office de
guichet unique puisque comme vous le
savez c'est très compliqué pour les
porteurs de projets innovants en France
de se repérer de d'être certain de
s'adresser au bon guichet ou au bon
interlocuteur au bon moment d'anticiper
les étapes successives notamment dans le
contexte de leur plan de développement
et d'anticiper notamment les demandes
qui seront faites par les autorités de
santé ultérieurement néanmoins
aujourd'hui l'agence est une petite
structure d'une dizaine de personnes on
sera 15 quand on sera au complet donc
elle ne pourra pas évidemment faire
office de guichet unique à ce stade même
si voilà la vocation aussi peut-être à
se développer donc on va fonctionner
selon une logique d'une part de
priorisation des projets innovants on a
ouvert en ligne une démarche simplifiée
qui permet aux porteur de projet de se
faire connaître auprès de l'agence et
puis à ce stade nous fonctionnons aussi
sur une logique partenariale notamment
avec l'ensemble des régions puisque il
est important de capitaliser sur tous
les dispositifs d'accompagnement qui
sont faits au niveau au niveau régional
on travaille notamment avec les tous les
services de l'État en région avec les
pôles de compétitivité avec les régions
elles-mêmes
et les incubateurs et accélérateurs au
niveau des territoires donc là on a
entrepris un tour de France de
l'innovation en santé qui nous permet
vraiment de commencer à identifier nos
interlocuteurs au sein des régions pour
pouvoir amplifier finalement notre
dispositif d'accompagnement et faire en
sorte que les bons projets nous soient
remontés de façon très sélective pour
pouvoir réellement avoir une capacité à
être le plus efficient possible dans ce
dispositif d'accompagnement qui est un
dispositif qu'on a mis en place selon
trois grands volets un premier volet qui
est un volet accès prioritaire donc là
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à négocier
avec nos partenaires et notamment les
autorités de santé des processus
accélérés pour les projets innovants
prioritaires labellisés par l'IS qui ne
seront pas des projets qu'on va choisir
seul bien évidemment mais en lien avec
l'interministériel et les agences
concernées puisque ce sont elles qui
sont en premier lieu concernées par ces
dispositifs accélérés
donc ça va concerner notamment les
autorisations pour le lancement des
essais cliniques on a un enjeu en France
même si beaucoup d'efforts ont été
réalisés dans le domaine de la recherche
clinique depuis les dernières années à
avoir la capacité à mener des essais de
face précoce on sait qu'aujourd'hui pour
que les patients aient accès aux
produits innovants il est il est majeur
que les essais de fassent précoce
puissent se mener aussi en France pour
pouvoir ensuite réellement se développer
de façon harmonieuse et que les les
praticiens hospitaliers les cliniciens
puissent avoir accès à ces traitements
on sait qu'il y a notamment dans les
médicaments de thérapie innovantes des
enjeux organisationnels à travailler et
c'est aussi en ayant accès aux produits
le plus tôt possible que cela peut se
mettre en place sachant que sur des
médicaments thérapie innovantes on voit
bien qu'on a aujourd'hui des modèles qui
sont assez différentes qu'on a pu
connaître par le passé avec des centres
de production qui vont être assez peu
nombreux en Europe et des centres de
traitement également qui risquent de ne
pas être extrêmement nombreux puisque ça
nécessite des organisations extrêmement
particulières le deuxième volet du
process accompagnement que l'agence va
mettre en place c'est un volet que je
veux qu'on va appeler hors cadre pour
permettre de faire évoluer le cadre
qu'il soit réglementaire juridique
organisationnel pour permettre aux
innovations qui sont tellement
disruptives qu'elles sont totalement
elles ne peuvent pas rentrer dans le
cadre existant et donc là c'est notre
équipe et notre pôle accélération
accompagnement qui va contribuer en lien
avec encore une fois les ministères et
les institutions à faire évoluer le
cadre existant et puis enfin un
accompagnement qu'on va appeler passage
à l'échelle pour vraiment permettre aux
innovations de trouver les conditions
les plus favorables pour se déployer que
ce soit en France ou à l'international
donc voilà un petit peu pour le la
déclinaison de ce processus
d'accompagnement et donc le dernier pôle
de l'agence qui va voilà contribuer sur
des sur un plan beaucoup plus systémique
et structurel à l'accélération et à la
transformation
du cadre existant si c'est nécessaire
pour pouvoir accélérer le développement
des innovations
si
c'est vrai que l'agence est une version
en santé au départ tout le monde a dit
mais pourquoi créer une nouvelle agence
il y a déjà pas mal d'agences dans le
paysage c'est déjà assez complexe
néanmoins ont défendait enfin moi je
défendais cette idée d'agence de
l'innovation de santé dans la mesure où
vous êtes attendu vous étiez attendu
quand même comme justement ce fédérateur
et elle rattachement
interministériel me semble bien se
fédérateur et est-ce qu'il allait se
simplificateur par rapport aux fatras
que celui de l'innovation et des
difficultés que rencontre les chercheurs
les promoteurs ou autres donc bon j'ai
bien compris que le guichet unique avec
15 personnes n'étaient plus possible
mais si vous pouvez je laisser la parole
ensuite un idéalement que qui a préparé
des questions
qui a fait un rapport sur l'innovation
et Véronique Guillotin également
un peu nous
vous préciser comment vous allez vous
vous positionner dans ce paysage par
rapport aux autres agences et puis par
rapport à
au choix des IHU hier moi j'étais parti
sur on avait dit il y aura une sélection
de projets il y avait une première
sélection il y avait eu ensuite des
euros qui ont été passés par les
candidats au CHU moi j'étais en lien
notamment avec Ken Salomon sur les hachu
cancer des femmes de curry
et puis en fait on arrive à une forme
quand même même si j'entends tous les
projets étaient bien mais une forme de
plus de saupoudrage le terme peut-être
un peu exagéré puisqu'on est sur un
nombre supérieur Dhu
choisi avec de fait puisque l'enveloppe
était constante des financements
moindres pour ça chaque et insu
ça traduit un peu cette difficulté qu'on
a à prioriser et à choisir finalement on
le voit dans plein de domaines on l'a vu
hier quand on a fait une audition sur
les données de santé très intéressante
c'était simple on a du mal à choisir par
rapport à d'autres pays à bien
structurer et je voulais avoir votre
votre sentiment là-dessus mais ni à
préparer des questions
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
la Directrice générale c'est vrai qu'on
avait beaucoup d'attentes par rapport à
l'arrivée de cette de cette agence
d'innovation en santé bon on voit bien
là que on en est pas on n'est pas en
rythme de croisière que vous allez
évoluer
est-ce que les enfin je pense que les
compétences actuelles de l'agence vont
s'enrichir
et
le
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on va arriver
infinie quand même un guichet unique
voilà vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
mais c'est encore en discussion et
d'autre part
j'aurais voulu savoir où on était le
plan le déploiement du plan innovation
en santé pour 2030
que normalement l'agence pour
l'innovation en santé chargée de suivre
et il y a une autre question aussi
l'agence de l'innovation santé a été
créée pour pour l'investissement et
placer sous l'autorité de la première
ministre est-ce que ça vous a qu'est-ce
que ça apporte ce positionnement et
normalement on pensait que c'était
plutôt une compétence nationale est-ce
que
vous allez garder un certain niveau
d'autonomie par rapport à ça
et enfin de quel moyen financier et
humain est-ce que vous allez disposer en
vitesse de croisière cette fois-ci
merci beaucoup pour pour ces questions
madame la Présidente je vais répondre
sur votre question qui est effectivement
tout à fait
pertinente sur le la question de notre
capacité
avoir une vision claire des priorités
portées alors je pense qu'il y a deux
niveaux de réponse d'une part de façon
très très concrète sur les décisions qui
ont été prises sur les IHU annoncé hier
je pense qu'il faut quand même souligner
que ces décisions ont été prises sur la
base des retours d'un jury indépendant
et qui a souligné de façon très très
claire de façon très claire la grande la
très grande qualité scientifique de tous
les projets qui ont été lauréat hier
donc je pense que on peut que se
féliciter d'avoir des projets vraiment
particulièrement intéressants sur le
plan scientifique avec des équipes de
grandes qualités que je tiens vraiment à
souligner donc voilà on peut voir le
verre à moitié plein moitié vide en tout
cas si on le voit à moitié plein on a
vraiment des des beaux projets en France
je pense que c'est un très bon un très
bon message aussi et ça va encourager
aussi à ces projets ces projets à
vraiment voir le jour à se concrétiser
et puis je voudrais souligner aussi
qu'effectivement il y a un certain
nombre de projets qui sont peut-être
moins murs ou en tout cas qui
nécessitent un accompagnement plus fort
que d'autres mais je tiens vraiment à
souligner que c'est des projets qui en
terme de santé publique qui sont
majeures
répartition une répartition géographique
exactement et ça c'est bien je sais que
le choix était très difficile
les projets émergents voilà sur le
domaine de vieillissement notamment sur
le domaine des maladies inflammatoires
chroniques de l'intestin on a des
projets aussi extrêmement importants sur
le les troubles du neuro-développement
de l'enfant donc je pense que voilà
c'est quand même des projets majeurs en
termes de santé publique aussi qui
convenait de soutenir me semble-t-il
donc je
voilà
je pense que ces projets là méritent non
seulement d'être suivi mais d'être
particulièrement encouragé alors après
pour aller peut-être dans un et pour
rejoindre sur le sujet de la prospective
et de notre capacité peut-être à définir
des lignes stratégiques claires sur nos
priorités y compris en matière de santé
publique je pense que l'idée aussi de
travailler sur la prospective en santé
et sur les besoins médicaux non couverts
va nous aider collectivement pour le
futur et en lien encore une fois avec
l'ensemble des ministères et l'Inserm à
définir nos priorités en matière de
recherche et peut-être aussi si nous
faisons des appels à projets futurs ou
des appels à manifestants intérêt être
capable de bien cibler nos priorités
peut-être pour faire émerger aussi des
projets prioritaires sur certaines
thématiques mais encore une fois je ne
peux en regardant la les projets
sélectionnés et financiers hier que me
réjouir de la diversité à la fois sur le
sur le plan géographique et sur le plan
des thématiques de santé publique
sur le les aspects des compétences de
l'agence et du guichet unique il va toi
que si vous interroger à titre personnel
je serai non seulement très enthousiaste
mais je pense que ça répond à un besoin
majeur de l'écosystème de faire office
de guichet unique parce que si on veut
simplifier jusqu'au bout
vraiment et
remplir cette mission de guide et
d'éclaireurs pour les porteurs de
projets que ce soit des porteurs publics
ou privés ça se ferait tout à fait sens
tout à fait logique que l'agence puisse
être un guichet unique et je serai la
première avis si ça pouvait se
concrétiser aujourd'hui
l'agence c'est une dizaine de personnes
encore une fois sur l'émission du suivi
du plan innovation santé France 2030
donc je récupère des ETP qui étaient au
secrétaire général pour investissement
et puis on a des missions qui vous
l'avez vu sont quand même assez vastes
avec tout le sujet de la prospective le
sujet de l'accompagnement j'ai quatre
personnes qui vont être en charge de
l'accompagnement et trois personnes sur
les enjeux
d'accélération et transformation donc
c'est vrai qu'avec quatre personnes qui
font de l'accompagnement faire un
guichet unique c'est pas c'est
aujourd'hui pas possible soyons clairs
sinon je vais le risque en affirmant le
fait que je suis un guichet unique si je
vais créer un goulot d'étranglement et
être totalement contre-productive et
déceptive donc je peux pas le faire
aujourd'hui mais je pense qu'il y a des
montages possibles en tout cas ça reste
dans les projets très clairement je
serai ravi de pouvoir le faire
effectivement le l'agence est en charge
du suivi du plan innovation santé France
2030 je pense que une grosse partie du
plan c'est quand même tous ces enjeux en
matière de recherche de médicale et on
l'a vu hier le plan avance très très
clairement aujourd'hui avec ces
infrastructures en matière de biologie
santé les chair les appels à projets qui
vont être lancés c'est mieux cluster et
sais qui ont été annoncés avec lesquels
on va pouvoir travailler désormais pour
pouvoir concrétiser un petit peu leur
leur déploiement et leur lancement sur
l'ensemble des stratégies d'accélération
tous les appels à projets ont été lancés
également alors évidemment ça se décline
au fil de l'eau mais on a je pourrais
vous
communiquer les résultats chiffrés pour
chaque stratégie d'accélération mais qui
se déploie très fortement
voilà pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur
on est autour de 13 milliards d'euros
sur les 54 milliards d'euros du plan
France 2030 sur toutes les verticales
donc voilà les choses se déploient de
façon
assez harmonieuse bien évidemment on va
on va poursuivre les efforts pour ce
déploiement en particulier sur le plan
des m innovants qui a été lancé
secondairement et qu'on va s'attacher à
suivre peut-être vous indiquer aussi que
au-delà des stratégies déjà existantes
nous réfléchissons aussi au sein de
l'agence de l'innovation en santé même
si à ce stade évidemment aucun arbitrage
n'a été
fait et ce sont des réflexions tout à
fait préliminaires mais nous sommes
particulièrement intéressés et c'est
dans la lettre de mission de l'Agence à
une réflexion autour de la contribution
de l'innovation à la mise en œuvre d'une
politique de prévention ambitieuse pour
reprendre des termes de la lettre de
mission et il nous semble que l'agence
de l'innovation est en rattaché
évidemment au ministère de la santé et
de la prévention parmi les trois
ministères auxquels nous rapportons et
on parle bien du ministère de la santé
et de la prévention et nous sommes que
c'est une composante qui est peut-être
pas suffisamment
comment dirais-je mise en exergue au
niveau du Plan Santé France 2030 donc on
aimerait enrichir possiblement
ce plan avec cette cette composante qui
nous paraît majeure avec aujourd'hui
notamment un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui n'ont pas aujourd'hui la
capacité de se déployer en matière de
prévention parce que pas de cadre soit
d'évaluation soit de prise en charge et
ça nous intéresse de travailler sur ce
sujet donc peut-être un élément
complémentaire qu'on aimerait apporter
et en matière d'autorité effectivement
l'agence est placé sous l'autorité de la
première ministre puisqu'elle est elle
est rattachée administrativement en
secrétaire régional pour
l'investissement je pense que là aussi
la lettre de mission laisse une certaine
forme d'ouverture sur ce que deviendra
l'agence et son statut juridique
notamment à ce stade avec l'agence n'est
pas
n'a pas de statut propre elle est un
service du secrétaire régional pour
l'investissement
ce qui a ce qui a eu la capacité de
permettre à l'agence de se créer très
rapidement sans passer par un texte
législatif quel qu'il soit qui encre
dans le marbre ou qui grave dans le
verbe ses missions
néanmoins c'est vrai que sur le plan
notamment budgétaire
l'agence étant une mesure du plan son
budget donc qui représente 100 millions
d'euros dans le cadre du Plan France
2030 n'est pas mobilisable donc je n'ai
pas la capacité aujourd'hui de mobiliser
du budget puisque ce budget doit passer
par un opérateur le secrétaire général
pour l'investissement ne pouvant pas
mobiliser lui-même du budget France 2030
donc c'est vrai qu'à ce stade moi je
n'ai pas de budget propre évidemment et
c'est ça fait partie des sujets sur
lesquels effectivement il faudra
certainement
mener des réflexions pour pas mettre à
l'agence de
d'avoir la capacité à se développer et à
mener à bien ses missions sur le plan
humain donc effectivement aujourd'hui
l'agence avec le suivi du plan France
2030 qui avait déjà un certain nombre de
TP on nous sommes 15 tout dépendra de
l'ambition qu'on veut donner à l'agence
il y avait aussi toute une réflexion
autour d'une barda à la française
et des enjeux apportés également le
sujet de la résilience face aux crises
au niveau de l'international d'être un
interrupteur de era là encore tout
dépendra de la place qu'on veut donner à
l'agence sur ces aspects là je j'ai été
évidemment en lien avec la mission
courage sur les réflexions autour d'une
mission de crise au sein du ministère
donc je pense que tout ça devrait être
réfléchi également en articulation avec
ces
réflexions et les conclusions de ces
missions puisqu'il s'agit pas évidemment
pas dupliquer ce qui devra être fait
mais plutôt travailler en coordination
avec ses réflexions qui sont en cours
merci présidente merci Madame alter pour
votre exposé en tout cas vous sont
passionnés par votre fonction je vous
souhaite plein de réussite dans vos
missions moi j'avais deux trois petites
questions à vous poser je suis membre de
la commission d'enquête sur la pénurie
des médicaments on sait qu'en France
sera un peu plus de 3000 médicaments qui
sont en situation de pénurie sans
compter ceux qui sont en tension et
c'est 37% de la population qui qui est
en manque de certains médicaments alors
est-ce que dans vos missions vous avez
justement cet axe là qui est de soutenir
l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour pallier à cette
pénurie deuxième question
il y a beaucoup de on parle toujours de
la fuite des cerveaux puisque je crois
qu'il y a 13% de nos chercheurs qui
travaillent à l'étranger comment est-ce
que vous allez pouvoir les attirer en
France finalement parce qu'on aura
besoin de toute cette matière grise pour
travailler sur ces différents sujets et
enfin on a vécu pendant l'épidémie covid
là on a
attendu vainement avec un Français
comment est-ce que vous allez travailler
dans les années à venir justement pour
mettre en place une structure qui nous
permette de répondre rapidement aux
nouvelles maladies infectieuses qui
pourraient arriver merci
Jocelyne guidez
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
suis toujours étonnée qu'on fasse des
millefeuilles alors qu'il y a des
structures qui existent déjà et je vois
pas trop ce qui vous différencie un peu
des autres surtout quand vous donne même
pas de moyens financiers la presse que
vous nous avez dit mais bon ça c'est une
réflexion personnelle je voulais savoir
si vous avez des partenariats avec des
autres pays
par rapport à votre à votre travail et
par rapport à l'innovation et si oui
lesquels
et moi je voudrais terminer ce qu'on a
pas d'autres inscrits
j'ai rencontré
lundi une
Biotte enfin une biotech et thérapie
génique alors on sait bien que la grande
majorité de l'innovation est faite par
ces biotech
notamment dans le cas des thérapies
géniques puisque c'est le sujet que
j'abordais lundi
en effet que des médicaments de rupture
a été faits des effets thérapeutiques de
long terme mais souvent après unique
or c'est biotech reste très fragile
économiquement et
il semble nécessaire peut-être de mettre
pour ces traitements des des mécanismes
de tarification adaptés est-ce que vous
au sein de l'agence innovation santé par
rapport à la mission qui a lancé
Elisabeth borne sur ce sujet est-ce que
vous avez des propositions de mécanismes
est-ce que ce sera le rôle de la chance
de faire des propositions on parle de la
création d'un label par exemple pour les
pour ces biotech ou alors dans le cas du
du
paiement et est-ce qu'on peut leur
accorder un paiement majoré lors de la
première administration du traitement
parce qu'elle semblerait être concernée
par un problème plutôt d'étalement des
paiements alors c'est très technique ce
que je dis est très
particulier mais est-ce que l'agence ma
question pour être plus simple est-ce
que l'agence va faire des propositions
dans ce sens pour favoriser les biotechs
pour pour éviter qu'elles sont en
difficulté et qu'elle et qu'elle et
qu'elle part ailleurs un ami long avait
une question
oui merci madame la présidente madame je
vous ai écouté avec peu d'attention au
départ parce que il y a beaucoup
d'attention à la fin et j'avoue que j'ai
pas tout compris
vous dites que vous êtes directrice
d'une agence pour lesquelles les statuts
n'ont pas encore été mises en place si
j'ai compris ce que vous avez dit
comment pouvez-vous donc justifier votre
type de directrice
ensuite
qu'elle va être quelle va être sur le
selon vous le positionnement de votre
agence par rapport à l'Inca par exemple
par rapport au plan présidentiel anti
Alzheimer anti autisme par rapport au
biotech par rapport aux universités aux
recherches universitaires
par rapport
au CHU par rapport à certains hôpitaux
comme Gustave Roussy qui font des
recherches considérables est-ce que vous
êtes une agence
dans le cas de l'innovation de la santé
qui va financer ou une agence qui va
faire des recherches
plus compléter on a eu une audition très
intéressante avec la commission de
transparence de la HAS récemment que
vous connaissez bien et je voulais
savoir comment vous allez vous articuler
par rapport à elle
oui vous avez raison vous avez raison
non mais j'ai
essayé de vous expliquer donc déjà il y
a d'autres agences de l'innovation qui
existent donc je ne suis pas une je ne
crée pas impressionnant notamment
l'agence de l'innovation défense
non non mais vous allez voir je vais
essayer de vous rassurer vous allez
comprendre vous allez comprendre parce
que c'est une agence qui a fait beaucoup
de bien à la DGA notamment
cette agence de l'innovation défense a
été créée vraiment pour voilà créer une
dans la défense évidemment donc tout
n'est pas transposable mais pour pour
stimuler pour créer vraiment un
changement de l'intérieur pour favoriser
tous ces enjeux d'innovation et on sait
à quel point
compris dans le domaine de la défense
tous les enjeux de santé ont été ont été
intégrés pendant la crise covid
notamment
donc cette agence avait un statut
juridique de service à compétences
nationales donc c'était un service de la
DGA il y avait bien un directeur là
aussi qui est toujours là d'ailleurs
Patrick Aufort donc qui travaille au
sein de la DGA donc c'est une structure
effectivement et c'est une petite
structure je pense que les agences
d'innovation même si elles peuvent se
développer évidemment et d'ailleurs le
rapport de préfiguration d'agence de
l'innovation en Santé prévoit une agence
environ 80 personnes ça n'a pas vocation
à non plus à devenir des monstres bien
évidemment mais voilà toute la question
de savoir jusqu'où on va et quels sont
les missions sans évidemment et je
réponds aussi à votre question madame
arriver enfin en tout cas en essayant de
ne pas tomber dans les cueille d'un
mille-feuille et ça c'est vraiment très
important de l'avoir en tête l'agence de
l'innovation en santé a vraiment
vocation et c'est pour ça que son
rattachement interne ministériel est
intéressant et important à faire en
sorte de stimuler de coordonnées et de
faire en sorte que justement
tous les efforts des uns et des autres
ne soient pas contre-productifs mais
dans le même sens ça a l'air de
effectivement de rajouter une couche et
moi-même quand j'ai pris mes fonctions
je vous avoue que je me suis aussi posé
la question mais je le vois tous les
jours
parfois il faut perdre un petit peu de
temps pour gagner et notamment perdre un
peu de temps de coordination et de
raccrocher les wagons pour être sûr
qu'on va dans la même direction et on
voit bien que sur notamment les
commandes de vaccins pendant la crise
covid il y avait des enjeux
interministériels forts et s'il y avait
une structure peut-être en capacité de
coordonnées piloter un petit peu tout ça
ça aurait certainement aidé à bien
avancer dans le bon sens tous ensemble
je dis pas que c'est simple bien au
contraire et j'évite tous les jours
l'exercice de l'interministérialité je
sais que c'est pas assez pas trivial
mais c'est d'autant plus important qui
cette structure là donc peut-être pour
vous répondre à ce stade l'agence n'a
pas le statut de service à compétence
nationale comme là l'agence de
l'innovation défense ou même Lancy sur
la cybersécurité qui est aussi un
service à compétence nationale
néanmoins dans ma lettre de mission il
est clairement indiqué que
le statut de juridique de l'agence devra
être réfléchi donc il y a plusieurs
hypothèses qui ont été
proposées dans le cadre du rapport de
préfiguration un GIP ou un service à
compétence nationale notamment donc
voilà les choses sont en cours de
réflexion et ça a un impact
effectivement surtout pour le budget pas
tellement pour la capacité de l'agence à
avancer concrètement puisque je le fais
déjà et j'attends pas d'avoir un statut
juridique pour travailler et je pense
que c'est plutôt une bonne chose que les
choses soient lancées concrètement pour
pouvoir avancer
et voilà je pense que
en tout cas le fait que je sois la
directrice et que je gère cette agence à
part voilà le cette question de statut
juridique j'ai quand même une lettre de
mission de la première ministre qui a
soit cette qui a soit ses missions là je
pense que ça m'empêche pas de travailler
aujourd'hui
j'ai répondu à votre question
oui par contre vous me demandez comment
il faut que je réponde à la deuxième
partie comment j'interagis avec un cas
avec les priorités de santé publique du
gouvernement avec les universités des
CHU et est-ce que je suis une agence de
financement ou de recherche encore une
fois
l'agence n'a pas vocation à se
substituer aux agences existantes je ne
vais pas reprendre les missions de
l'Inka ou l'émission de la Haute
Autorité de santé ou de la NSM qui sont
des agences et des opérateurs qui ont un
rôle d'évaluation
pour la HS un rôle également pour la NSM
d'agence du médicament en revanche j'ai
un rôle de de coopération de partenariat
avec ces agences justement pour faire en
sorte que les projets innovants
prioritaires puissent être traités de
façon particulièrement rapide un peu
comme on l'a fait pendant la crise covid
sur un certain nombre de projets qui
étaient
urgent et prioritaire il s'agit pas de
tout prioriser bien loin de là mais sur
un petit pourcentage du flux et sur des
projets sur lesquels on est vraiment en
phase avec des agences sanitaires
vraiment essayer de mettre tous nos
efforts pour que les délais
administratifs et c'est bien cela dont
on se préoccupe puisse être raccourci
qu'on puisse vraiment accélérer les
innovations et je pense que c'est un
enjeu majeur notamment pour les biotech
aujourd'hui puisque deux ou trois mois
pour une biotech ça suffit pour lui
faire mettre la clé sous la porte très
clairement on peut pas comparer le
modèle économique des gros industriels
et le modèle économique des biotech il
faut aller extrêmement vite pour leur
permettre de se développer ces critiques
et c'est pour ça qu'une structure qui
les accompagne de A à Z qui les prend
par la main et leur montre justement où
sont les bons guichets puisqu'il y a des
guichets aujourd'hui existants au niveau
de la NSM le guichet innovation notation
qui fonctionne très bien je pense il y a
aussi des Fastrack côté HS avec les
accès précoce mais parfois les biotech
ne les connaissent pas elles ne savent
même pas que ça existe et l'agence est
là justement pour leur dire voilà vous
voudrez ce dispositif là saisissez vous
en et je pense que ça peut paraître
redondant mais ça ne l'est pas du tout
puisque aujourd'hui personne ne vient
vers elle en leur disant voilà c'est
c'est
ce schéma là qu'il faut et cette
direction qu'il faut prendre donc on
élève vraiment pour ça donc on ne se
substitue pas encore une fois ni à
l'Inca ni aux agences sanitaires et on
travaille en lien main dans la main au
quotidien avec les universités avec les
CHU avec l'IGR qui est le PSC notamment
et et on fonctionne selon cette logique
partenariale et notre objectif et c'est
ça qui est clé dans l'innovation c'est
de faire office de catalyseur en fait
c'est comme dans une réaction chimique
si vous mettez pas les ingrédients les
uns avec les autres ça prend pas et je
pense que c'est vraiment l'enjeu là
aussi
ouais mais on espère bien que les
experts bien que la France va permettre
une explosion des innovations dans les
années qui viennent
non non mais réellement et d'ailleurs
c'est l'objectif des bioclusteurs et
l'agence fonctionne dans cette dans
cette objective là de faire en sorte que
les gens se parlent et fonctionnent
ensemble je vais vous donner des
exemples très concrets sur notamment
aujourd'hui on a des des objectifs à
avancer sur la structuration des
biogangs déco-orte ça concerne beaucoup
de parties prenantes mais aujourd'hui si
on fait pas en sorte que se parle les
établissements de santé les CRB l'Inserm
si tout ça ne communique pas on n'arrive
pas à avancer donc vraiment je pense que
c'est crucial aujourd'hui qui est une
coordination parce que l'innovation ça
foisonne tout le monde en fait on a des
incubateurs des accélérateurs on a des
universités investis des pays des IHU
des bioclusteurs il faut vraiment qu'il
y ait une forme de vision globale à un
moment pour coordonner et pour faire en
sorte que les gens se parlent les
fonctionnent ensemble
bien sûr mais ce n'est pas incompatible
ne peut pas tout faire et ne peut pas
être enfin ne peut pas coordonner
lui-même mettre les gens autour de la
table et moi je suis finalement un petit
peu cette structure de stimulation de
pilotage et de coordination
les questions dans l'ordre pardonnez-moi
je me suis un peu perdue sur les
pénuries
alors ne figure pas dans la lettre de
mission de l'Agence
une mission
clairement affichée pénurie de
médicaments bien évidemment puisque nous
sommes pas là des jeux ni ministère de
l'Industrie néanmoins à travers les
enjeux de réindustrialisation
d'industrialisation notamment ce qui
concerne les bios procédés et la
bioproduction qui est un une des
thématiques importantes du plan France
2030 sur la verticale santé
on favorise des innovations en matière
de procédés de production qui sont soit
plus vertueux avec une décarbonation
soit innovant matière de roi on va dire
donc je pense qu'à travers ces
investissements en matière de bioprocédé
nouveau bioprocédé au procès de
production tout simplement
ses vertueux et ça va contribuer de
façon indirecte
à permettre à des projets puisque
souvent il y a des projets mixtes il y a
pas que des projets innovants qui sont
menés par ces
entreprises ou ses projets en matière de
d'industrialisation et de production
donc ça va permettre de faire effet de
levier et d'amener aussi peut-être des
projets de relocalisation de molécules
critiques ou même de d'API donc je pense
que indirectement ça va contribuer mais
c'est évidemment pas le coeur de la
mission de l'Agence
sur le sujet de la fuite des cerveaux
également donc je citer le l'appel à
projet qui va être ouvert dans les jours
qui viennent peut-être même aujourd'hui
sur les chairs en santé qui a été
annoncé hier par le Président de la
République donc c'est 50 chers de
recherche en biologie santé qui vont
permettre
d'attirer et de maintenir sur notre
territoire des talents en matière de
recherche pardon
des talents en matière de recherche on a
bien en tête que les talents c'est
crucial et d'ailleurs dans le plan
France 2030 et un enjeu formation avec
un appel à manifestation compétences et
métiers d'avenir les enjeux de formation
et de compétences sont clés pour
l'innovation et on a aujourd'hui des
facteurs limitants importants notamment
sur ça peut paraître trivial mais des
postes de techniciens notamment pour
tous ces nouveaux biocrossés donc ça
c'est quelque chose sur lequel on
travaille également des compétences en
affaires réglementaires pour permettre
de résoudre des problématiques qu'on
connaît bien sur les organismes notifiés
puisque c'est ça le facteur limitant
aujourd'hui pour avoir des évaluations
plus rapides
donc on est on est très mobilisé
effectivement sur cette nécessité de
d'attirer en France et de maintenir sur
le territoire national et on espère
vraiment toutes ces annonces sur les la
recherche va permettre d'y contribuer
sur le vaccin l'anesthésie d'avoir des
vaccins français donc on a une stratégie
effectivement sur les maladies
infectieuses émergentes donc on a des
appels à projets aujourd'hui en cours
effectivement pour contribuer à faire en
sorte qu'on ait à la fois une capacité
d'innovation mais aussi de production en
France sur le plan de la vaccinologie on
a plusieurs projets qui sont en cours
d'instruction évidemment donc on peut
pas en parler aujourd'hui mais en tout
cas il y a des choses qui et on essaie
vraiment d'y contribuer je pense que la
création également d'un biocluster à
Lyon autour des maladies infectieuses
émergentes va permettre là encore
d'asseoir une forme de
cluster national qui va permettre aussi
de rendre plus visible l'investissement
de la France en la matière et de
permettre de coordonner aussi les
travaux sur le domaine à la fois
d'infectieux et de la vaccinologie en
tout cas c'est une vraie priorité de
France 2030 et nous avons une
coordinatrice dédiée sur ces sur ces
gens-là qui travaillent au
à la au suivi du plan sur ces sur ces
domaines
sur des partenariats avec les autres
pays donc évidemment l'agence à vocation
comment
pardon
l'agence c'est évidemment intéressé de
travailler à l'international sauf que
vous comprenez bien que on vient d'être
lancé on a on a des enjeux majeurs et un
plan d'envergure à suivre donc j'ai
recruté une personne au niveau de
l'agence qui va nous aider à créer du
lien avec l'international c'est crucial
notamment avec era qui est qui travaille
dans ce dans cet objectif de préparation
face aux crises c'est important d'avoir
cette ce focus international pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui tout ce qui
concerne l'évaluation des produits de
santé notamment que ce soit les AMM les
organismes notifiés mais aussi demain
l'évaluation est chié donc elle
technologie sessment avec notamment un
état qui prépare les évaluations au
niveau européen je pense que tout ce qui
va concerner notamment les délais
d'évaluation qui sont critiques pour les
produits innovants
va se dérouler au niveau européen donc
il est important qu'on puisse bien
suivre ça en lien évidemment avec les
agences sanitaires et le svae qui
puisque la France ne parle que d'une
seule voix évidemment en la matière mais
on est évidemment très intéressé de
suivre de près notamment ces enjeux de
délai puisqu'on a des dispositifs
aujourd'hui d'accès précoce en France
qui sont assez uniques et qu'on ne
voudrait certainement pas perdre parce
que l'évaluation va se faire demain
niveau européen je sais que la HS est
très engagée sur le sujet mais on y sera
particulièrement vigilant parce qu'il
est vraiment important d'avoir le
maintien de ces dispositifs précoces y
compris dans un contexte européen en
tout cas pour répondre à la question sur
les partenariats avec d'autres pays on
espère évidemment les concrétiser pour
l'instant
on prend les contacts bien sûr et on est
en contact d'ores et déjà avec era pour
ces enjeux effectivement de coordination
dans l'anticipation de crise sanitaire à
venir
sur le contexte particulier des biotech
des biotech et des Matech aussi
d'ailleurs effectivement ce sont des
structures tout à fait particulières
puisque le modèle économique n'est
évidemment pas simple ce sont des
entreprises particulières dont le temps
de développement extrêmement long il
faut entre 10 et 20 ans pour une biotech
de pouvoir passer à la clinique et
démontrer la valeur de ces innovations
aujourd'hui en plus on est dans un
contexte où des fonds d'investissement
sont particulièrement
attentif aux investissements qu'ils font
et les investissements les plus risqués
sont parfois ceux qui sont pas
privilégiés aujourd'hui donc je pense
qu'on a un enjeu aussi notamment à faire
en sorte que les initiatives telles que
les initiatives tibi puissent vraiment
se lancer et se relancer pour pouvoir
contrer un petit peu ce contexte là qui
est pas simple pour les pour les biotech
je pense que c'est d'autant plus
important qui est un label agence de
l'innovation aujourd'hui qui se mettent
en place
justement pour leur permettre d'avoir de
la lisibilité en français à
l'international pour pouvoir être
financé et pour qu'il y ait des
investissements alors on a commencé à le
faire le dispositif d'accompagnement de
l'agence et d'ores et déjà fonctionnel
puisqu'on accompagne d'ores et déjà les
20 premières entreprises lauréate du
programme S20 de la French tech avec un
partenariat de l'agence innovation santé
donc on commence déjà à mettre à mettre
en musique ce dispositif
d'accompagnement pour voilà permettre à
ces startups de se déployer donc
évidemment donc tout le travail de
l'agence en termes de visibilité pour
permettre à des fonds privés de de
contribuer à aider ces biotech le
travail également en lien avec BPI
France qui a contributeur majeur aussi
pour les biotech c'est un opérateur de
France 2030 donc c'est un partenaire
quotidien avec lequel on travaille
évidemment très bien
et puis vous évoquez le contexte d'une
tarification adaptée au modèle
économique même des médicaments de
thérapie innovantes avec donc
effectivement des traitements one shot
et des persistances et très cher de
l'ordre d'un million d'euros notamment
et une persistance de l'effet qui va sur
plusieurs années mais finalement avec un
recul encore assez limité même si
parfois il est il est de l'ordre de
plusieurs années mais on ne sait pas
jusqu'où il va
donc effectivement on attend avec
beaucoup de beaucoup d'impatience
également les recommandations de la
mission en régulation et financement qui
va certainement faire des
recommandations les réflexions de
l'agence à ce stade elles sont
évidemment très préliminaires mais on a
bien conscience que on parlait de fonds
d'investissement peut-être que l'idée
encore une fois je
euh ce que je vais vous dire là ne va
pas vous paraître où nous avons été
auditionnés par la Mission effectivement
qui est je pense très intéressé
notamment sur tout le volet horizon
scanning et prospective parce qu'en fait
c'est le nerf de la guerre pour pouvoir
anticiper et faire des
comment dire
oui anticiper la réalité des innovations
dans le domaine du financement il faut
voir sur du pluriel et il faut avoir
cette capacité à voir loin et avoir un
horizon scanning de bonne qualité
qui se structure et d'ailleurs font
pourra peut-être en dire un mot mais on
a décidé dans ce contexte là
effectivement de lancer des travaux
prioritaires sur les médicaments
thérapie innovantes en matière d'horizon
scanning parce qu'on peut pas s'attaquer
à tout
fondé à mes côtés le seul à travailler
sur sur le sujet au niveau de l'agence
puisqu'on n'est pas très nombreux mais
en tout cas il a il a priorisé les
médicaments de thérapie innovantes pour
nous permettre de lancer des travaux dès
maintenant et on est en contact
évidemment avec l'ensemble des
interlocuteurs pour déjà rassembler
toutes les initiatives qui existent et
qui sont nombreuses qui sont de part pas
de rien
sur le domaine mais on va essayer de le
structurer pour permettre de donner de
la visibilité donc c'est le sujet
prioritaire sur lequel l'agence est
investi effectivement ce domaine de
l'horizon scanning et après
effectivement on n'a pas la solution
miracle pour travailler sur la
tarification mais effectivement les
jeûnements sur du pluriel ça paraît
évidemment important et il y a aussi
l'enjeu peut-être de réfléchir à des
systèmes effectivement de fonds
d'amorçage de fonds d'investissement qui
permettent un petit peu de voilà qui
sont un peu disruptif et qui permettent
de passer des caps un peu compliqué on
va avoir finalement avoir des absorbé
des coûts majeurs surtout que ces
innovations arrivent dans des
indications parfois plus larges que
celles développées jusqu'à présent ou
c'était des indications niches dans des
sous-groupes de population très très
restreint
merci nous en avons terminé il y a pas
d'autres questions écoutez merci vous
avez été mis sur le grill sur cette
c’était un plaisir merci beaucoup mais
c'est important pour nous de voir en
effet comment vous situiez dans ce
paysage et comme il y a beaucoup
d'annonces sur l'innovation enfin pour
ma part les choses se sont clarifiées
voilà et puis je suis à votre
disposition évidemment d'une part pour
clarifier les points qui mériteraient de
l'être et l'agence étant une structure
en construction et assez
voilà qui peut qui peut évoluer donc moi
je vous invite aussi et c'est vraiment
l'appel que j'aimerais passer
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que j'aimerais
vraiment co-construire aussi la feuille
de route de l'agence et si vous sentez
que possiblement on part dans la
mauvaise direction ou qu'il y a des
choses qu'il faut ajuster moi je préfère
qu'on y travaille aujourd'hui ensemble
plutôt que dans 10 ans me dise que je
suis partie à côté donc vraiment moi
c'est aussi un appel d'ouverture en
disant que je construis avec les régions
aujourd'hui mais voilà je suis à votre
disposition pour travailler sur nous
pour vous faire part de nos rem Arques
il y a différents rapports on voit
beaucoup de gens sur l'innovation reçoit
beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes dans
des domaines aussi bien la cancérologie
bien évidemment mais que ce soit sur les
maladies neurodégénératives d'autres
pathologies et c'est vrai que la
prévention il y a sûrement à mettre la
place de l'innovation en matière de
prévention où là il y a un retour sur
investissement non négligeable
pour financer tous ces médicaments et ne
vend très cher qui arrivent il va
falloir se trouver des marges de
manœuvre il y en a plusieurs et je pense
que la prévention est à court terme une
démarche de manœuvre les plus
importantes voilà merci beaucoup bonne
journée à vous bonne journée
il